[Music]
thank you
inappropriate promo code I'm not hip
enough to know what stringing someone is
but I know enough that they probably
shouldn't be advertising for people to
come strength this beauty also 90
seconds of previously logoning
nope there is no way that amount of
confetti stayed in that card when you
were holding it like this three seconds
ago gravity and Common Sense would have
at least indicated this envelope was
ready to burst long before you clumsily
spilled it all over your floor and it's
twice as much of a tend to kill a fun
person and Thrice is much of a sin for a
plot to separate the protagonist from
the sidekick they have amazing chemistry
with for the rest of the episode real
talk why does anyone have a wedding on a
Thursday right I recently had to attend
a wedding on a Friday not just any
Friday the Friday of Thanksgiving
weekend this sin is for anyone who
schedules any guilt attendance event on
any day other than a Saturday between
April and August my convenience is more
important than your Venue discount start
the remainder of your life in debt like
the rest of us yes it's a self-contained
wedding episode and if you think this is
happening at An Inconvenient time in the
season you're right she all Kings landed
on the fourth wall to do our job for us
cliche also most bridesmaids are
selected way in advance they're usually
part of the wedding planning so why is
Jen just getting noticed a few days
before the event seems like a massive
oversight on the part of the Bride or
the show just needed a way to drum up
some quick tension I'm thinking it's the
latter walking in heels on grass No
One's Gonna be looking at me you're
seven feet tall in green Jen everyone is
most certainly going to be looking at
you yeah obviously this is the one time
I didn't want to show up as just yet
roll commercial wait did they just
change the title card to be the title of
the episode instead of the show whoa
I've only read about this in this sends
lore of old all right I have to remember
my sin Academy training here I think
this calls for a sin factor of five I
don't recall if it's for the currency or
the current total sins though and since
I can't look it up because I lost my sin
manual and that freak PB J accident I
guess it's all up to me so uh here you
go I'm a good guy I don't want to hurt
anybody's feelings thinking that hurt
feelings are always a result of immoral
choices I do I die but only for a look
kind of die but I do die this die
conversation goes on for all the
sometime here's two sins for an unfunny
gag I'm sure they won't be repeating
and get your Immortal and everything but
other than comedic reasons why would you
lead with your face while going through
a window also aren't there other
liability issues here as well I'd like
to see Jen take the case of the family
of an innocent bystander he eventually
accidentally lands on top of of course
then we would send you four filching the
entire premise of the boys and
Invincible
Team Edward or Jacob I can't believe I
have to go over this again when this
joke was old in 2009 but Jacob ends up
being attracted to Bella's unborn baby
which is all kinds of yuck and Edward is
104 year old man who stalks a minor so
the real answer should be team FBI you
made it you're so busy though you have
like five thousand businesses wait so
you're worried everyone would be looking
at She-Hulk but you didn't consider that
a superstar like Titania would also draw
attention away from you on your big day
I'm sensing double standards and that's
worth double sins no no she has weasled
her way into this wedding to mess with
me that is so obvious why does nobody
else see that valid question and
honestly the level of oblivious
to that Lulu displays in the scene
actually makes me hate Jen for even
being her friend and I'm pretty sure
that was not the intended outcome my
plan was to strike up a very normal
conversation with
a beautiful woman stuff in her face with
candy nuts and I'm very good at sticking
to my plan yeah I can jump seriously it
doesn't matter who she's in a scene with
Titania masalani is absolutely magnetic
on screen am I gonna take a sin off for
her every single episode no but it won't
be for lack of trying I'm gonna ignore
the paper thin connecting of this B plot
to the season Arch you know what I'm not
it's in that nonsense but what's most
sinful here is that Nikki has written
down New Orleans jazz festival and you
don't need that apostrophe after the s
in New Orleans frankly all of these
spouses should be filing criminal
charges except they can't only
prosecuting attorney can file criminal
charges these victims can file civil
lawsuits which is what we're supposedly
doing here in this lawyer show that
can't lawyer half the time I will never
understand women if I live to be uh and
I will a very strange Avenue of sexism
for a man who was clearly also married
to a man who is also in this room making
everyone watch you play switch like this
instead of being courteous enough to
bring the dock and find a TV Kevin he's
so Brave we just had to resuscitate him
this morning so your dog died presumably
from the stress of living with you and
then when he came back you thought his
health was strong enough to attend a
wedding ceremony where he'd be
surrounded by hundreds of unfamiliar
scents people and sounds sounds like
abuse so here's five sins for that poor
pupper ladies Sebastian how about this
kudos to Marvel on the bisexual
visibility in the show this episode
casually Works in that detail about Mr
immortal's life without making a huge
fuss about it and it's the same with
Nikki's love life this show may not
lawyer well but it queers well and
that's worth a sent off we were married
for 18 years and she was only with him
for three what a strange way to work the
parable of the workers in the vineyard
into this Show's plot also why are all
these victims negotiating for themselves
shouldn't they all have attorneys
present for this divorce settlement
seems highly unlikely that at least one
of them wouldn't have brought their own
counsel
boy DJ Channel
Chad sitting cross-legged on the table
when there are plenty of chairs
available Miss Ramos unconventional and
excellent was the unconventional part
how she went against the very Integrity
of what it means to be a defense lawyer
and put her own personal feelings above
her clients or maybe how she didn't even
check with him before negotiating terms
with his former spouses because everyone
in the room rightfully hated him even
though she was literally supposed to be
the one in the room looking out for his
interests of the judicial system can
work yeah truly unconventional trying to
get a hold of me for weeks or months or
days or whatever right there with you
Jen watching the show can definitely
make me feel like days or weeks or
months are going by and you should see
what my She-Hulk hair looks like oh wait
why exactly does the hair change I've
never thought about the hair part of
this equation before but considering
hair follicles are dead cells they
really shouldn't be impacted and with
all the extra skull space wouldn't the
hair spread and thin out immensely it's
not like new follicles immediately grow
to fill the in between gaps and oh dear
sweet Lord in heaven what about the
fingernails
I considered removing a sin for a show
not actually showing vomiting for once
but then I realized Jen threw up in the
garden instead of finding a trash can or
a toilet nearby so my hands are tied
punching Jen before she's had time to
clean her face as M1 said mom's
spaghetti there's about to be vomit on
your knuckles already you had more than
one shot Titania there would have been
more than one opportunity why are you so
obsessed with me you know Jen's been
punched in the face by a being with
super strength went flying across the
patio and fell to the concrete trying to
punch Titania yet she doesn't even look
like she has a scratch on her even her
dress seems fine does she have powers in
human form that I don't know about
[Music]
I get needing to take on this fight but
upon becoming Giant and sober why is
destroying private property the first
thing She-Hulk does you aren't an out of
control Hulk you're a totally aware and
considered shulk stop it with the
disregard to the damage to the things
people around you so was this bridesmaid
stress-fitted for She-Hulk instead of
Jen it looked baggy on Jen is now
perfect for She-Hulk but why it's clear
that the bride never wanted She-Hulk to
show up from the beginning so how did
the fitting even go down we lose limit
of a wedding just keeps on getting
dumber and dumber so a little Googling
told me that Titania got her powers from
Doctor Doom and while that's not
relevant to this particular moment I'm
sending Marvel for introducing this
character before Dr Doom
my veneers yeah you hit the ground
pretty hard but is that more Force than
a punch from She-Hulk because she
punched you in the mouth a few seconds
ago and your veneers seemed just fine oh
Lulu I know I promised you actually only
promised not to show up as She Hulk to
the wedding and this is the reception
it's a separate event and is therefore
not bound by your prior verbal
commitment see I can lawyering the law
too the director said let's add
references to bitcoin and crypto to make
sure it's clear this fake profile
belongs to a bro hole I'm just saying
bidding the coin is the new biting the
apple and it's already tropy enough for
a sin some of these are death threats
Janice better off just
let her live her life I understand not
wanting to feed the Trolls but warning
Jen about threats on her life doesn't
give them attention it just lets her
know people are plotting against her and
that definitely seems like the safer
option oh no not the giant pointy thing
in the yellow triangle box is She-Hulk
and dance
must be fast I could never get the anger
first look
oh what's in the box taking all the
attention away from me with you
you know what the difference is between
you and me I make this look good I'm a
good guy I don't want to hurt anybody's
feelings but you know I was drunk and
angry and stupid and blogging and
blogging after any of the answers
[Music]
[Applause]
John you're so lucky Sonny you will be
sort of missed you little bat face piece
of so I think I had a class with
you oh yeah what class history maybe yes
I think that's what it was it don't
necessarily might not remember me you
know I like it here it doesn't mean
because I go here I'm a genius